Wir wollen jetzt blicken auf die Serie A, La Liga, die Premier League und die Ligue 1. Das tun wir mit Michael Postel, Alex Treuker, Christian Bernhardt und Uli Hebel. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost und das hier ist die Rasenfunk Ligatour. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Ich verstehe nicht, wie meine Gäste hier sitzen können, wie Denkmäler. Ich dachte schon, alle eures Dreams seien eingefroren. Aber gut, so ist es eben. Bin ich eben der Einzige, der sich über dieses Intro freut. Schön, dass ihr alle drei da seid. Uli Hebel wird noch später dazu kommen. Und wir machen gar nicht lange rum. Wir starten direkt rein in die Sendung. Alex, lass uns mal mit La Liga beginnen. Wir wollen nach Spanien blicken und erwerfen große Ereignisse, ihren Schatten, keine Ahnung, was das auf Spanisch heißt, voraus.
Große Ereignisse, ich glaube, du meinst wahrscheinlich zwei recht große Spiele. Die Länderspielpause flacht alles ein bisschen ab, aber es geht direkt Schlag auf Schlag weiter. Der nächste Woche empfängt der FC Barcelona den FC Bayern München. Zwei alte Bekannte. Das ging nicht immer so gut aus, aus Barca Sicht, wie man ja weiß in den letzten Jahren. Und dann verschnaufen ist nicht bei Barca, denn drei, vier Tage später gibt es den Klassiker. Ich bin da ehrlich, ich bin da noch nicht so erfreut drauf oder noch nicht so heiß, weil es ist ja auch Länderspielpause. Wir nehmen hier am Donnerstag auf. Man ist da noch nicht so drin, aber für Hansi Flick kommt es gleich Schlag auf Schlag richtig heiß. Also es war jetzt Anlaufzeit bisher, aber jetzt geht es ab für Flick und Koh.
Aber ich verstehe das natürlich nach der Länderspielpause. Wir alle müssen uns jetzt wieder neu fokussieren auf den Klubfußball. Aber wie kann denn das sein, dass du nicht bis in die letzte deiner Haarspitzen motiviert bist und gepalmt bist? Ich meine, Barca führt die Liga an mit 3 Punkten Vorsprung vor Real. Der Flick-Train ist am Rollen. Jetzt ist ja auch der Trainer, der diese empfindliche Niederlage Barca damals zugefügt hat, als Bayern-Trainer noch. Der hat die Seiten gewechselt. Wer weiß, welche Rolle dieses 2 zu 8 damals überhaupt gespielt hat. Also wie Alex kann es sein, dass du hier nicht Puls 180 und Vorfreude-Level 1000 hast?
Ja, weil, Länderspielpause, sag ich ja. Aber das ist ein gutes Stichwort. Es war ja der Trainer, genau, das 8 zu 2, 2 zu 8. Das war auch ein Grund. Denn Flicks Bayern haben da beeindruckt, ganz Europa natürlich, offenbar auch den Gegner und dementsprechend den Präsidenten des Gegners. Also Jordan Laporta hat sich gedacht, hey, sowas hätte ich auch gerne bei mir. Also wirklich, dieser Angriffsfußball, dieser pressingfußball, diese pressing- und Laufmaschinen des FC Bayern, die da Barca ja wirklich überrollt haben. Und das hat, glaube ich, auch einen Grund, oder war ein Grund, hat den Ausschlag gegeben, weil man gesagt hat, ey, wir wollen irgendwie etwas dieser DNA implementiert haben in unserem Verein. Und deswegen haben sie Flick auch geholt. Und tatsächlich sieht man schon ein paar Sachen davon. Muss man ehrlich sagen. Also klar, die Tabelle liest sich wunderbar, viel gewonnen und so. Aber die Art und Weise ist wirklich das, was man hier hervorheben kann, was auch Mut macht vor den Duellen gegen Real Madrid und den FC Bayern. Eben das, sie so laufstark sind, fitter sind als zuvor. Laut eigenen Aussagen auch der Spieler arbeiten sie fleißiger, akribischer im Training, sind fitter. Es wird mehr Hauptaugenmerk auf die fitness gelegt. Peter hat zum Beispiel gesagt, früher waren wir nach 70 Minuten mehr oder weniger platt. Und jetzt können wir noch einen draufsetzen. Das ist ja auch schon bemerkenswerte Kritik.
Wie kann denn das eigentlich sein? Ich verstehe das nicht.
Das ist bemerkenswert, dass es im Endeffekt ein Seitenhieb an Scharwe ist. Jetzt sind wir nicht mehr nach 70 Minuten platt. Das ist schon ungewöhnlich deutlich. Das spricht natürlich für Flick und Co. und für sein Team. Da wird offenbar gut gearbeitet. Die Mannschaft hat Bock, ist laufstark, legt auch nach. Die Führer 1.0 und früher oder 2.0 und früher wurde verwaltet. Jetzt sind sie wirklich in Bayern-Stile. deswegen können wir die Parallelen ein bisschen ziehen. Jetzt haben sie halt Bock, noch das dritte, vierte, fünfte Tor zu schießen, legen nach, sind giftig. Das macht ein bisschen Mut. Das gebe ich zu. Von daher läuft es bisher ganz gut. Aber Bayern und Real Madrid sind andere Gegner als bisher. Jetzt kommen die gerade besser.
Das wäre eben meine Frage gewesen. Wenn man sich die Spiele anguckt, die zum Teil mit vielen Toren gewonnen wurden– 28 hat man ja allein in der Liga geschossen– dann fehlen ebenso genau die richtig großen Gegner, würde ich sagen. Gleichzeitig habe ich den Eindruck, wir alle waren ein bisschen skeptischer. Ich habe noch mal eine Witze darüber gemacht. Ich bin noch nicht bereit, davon zurückzutreten. Aber kann es sein, dass Hansi Flick vielleicht ein moderner Felix Maggert ist, wenn es jetzt das nächste Team ist, wo er hinkommt? Und das heißt, krass, wir sind auf einmal fit und allein deshalb können wir besseren Fußball spielen. So meine ich das. Er macht es halt nicht mit Medizin-Bällen. Er macht es nicht mit Medizin-Bällen.
Gut, da fehlt mir jetzt der Blick hinter die Kulissen bei der Trainingsarbeit. Ich bin jetzt nicht ganz dabei, ob er Medizin-Bälle benutzt oder welche Art und Weise er in der Trainingslehre anwendet, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber sie legen einfach ein bisschen mehr Wert. Und das Hauptaugenmerk auf eine fitness und auf die Saisonvorbereitung, um eine solche aufzubauen. Und ich glaube, das ist schon mal ein bisschen anders. Von daher ist das ein frischer Wind, den man auch als Verein in der Trainingslehre gut gebrauchen kann. Das war eben meine Meinung, dass sie da mal einen anderen Impact brauchen. Er gilt aber auch wirklich als Freund der Spieler. Also es wird immer wieder auch in der presse darüber gesprochen, wie gut er sich mit jedem versteht, wie handel er ist, wie demütig nimmt jeden in den Arm, ist lernwillig quasi, will den Verein verstehen, lernen. Also es soll wohl wirklich auch von der Art und Weise her– und da kannst du vielleicht besser mehr dazu sagen, weil du in München näher dran warst– dass er wirklich auch eine sehr lebenswürdige Person ist. Und dadurch mischt sich das quasi. Also du kannst mit ihm über alles sprechen. Er ist ja Kumpeltyp, aber eben ein sehr, sehr fleißiger Trainer oder in der Trainingslehre sehr fleißig. Und ich glaube, das ergänzt sich so gut, dass man das bisher in der Tabelle ganz gut ablesen kann.
Pass auf, wahrscheinlich würde er jetzt bei Barca auch Erfolg haben und dann kommt raus, es war der DFB, weshalb er da so erfolglos war. Das würde einen ja auch nicht komplett wundern, wenn man ehrlich ist. Jetzt haben wir aber noch abschließende Frage dazu. Welche aktuellen Themen gibt es denn jenseits von Hansi Flick? Wir haben ja unserem Anderem einen verletzten Jamil Jamal.
Ja, der kam ein bisschen angeschlagen, muskuläre Probleme von der Länderspielpause zurück. Muss man abwarten. Barca sagt da immer, er hat da ein bisschen was am Fuß oder am Oberschenkel. Man muss mal schauen, wie es ihm geht. Mehr geben sie da nicht raus. Ansonsten positiv ist natürlich, definitiv zu erwähnen, dass zum Beispiel Dani Olmer zurückkehrt, dass Frenkie de Jong zurückgekehrt ist, weil er bis jetzt schon zwei Kurzeinsätze hatte. Der fiel ja auch, glaube ich, fünf Monate oder so aus. Gar wie nach Kreuzbandriss steht unmittelbar vor dem Comeback. Also allein das sind ja drei essenziell wichtige Mittelfeldspieler, die Barca zuletzt abgingen. Und auch deswegen musst du Flick noch mal einen Ticken mehr loben, wenn man darauf guckt, mit welcher Mannschaft er diese Ergebnisse eingefahren hat und vor allem die Art und Weise, wie er gespielt hat. Also mit Lauter, 19-, 18-, 17-, 20-Jährigen, die davor in der dritten Liga spielten, also in der zweiten Mannschaft bei Barca Athletic gar nicht so vorgesehen waren, dass er jetzt unbedingt den Sprung zu den Profis machen werden. Also nicht jeder ist so ein Supertalent wie Lamine Jamal als Beispiel oder Kubasi. Klar, der gilt als Supertalent, weil ich Uli hier gerade sehe. Über den haben wir eh schon mal gesprochen. Aber alle anderen, so Marc Casado und Co., die helfen quasi nur aus, weil es keine anderen gibt. Und die machen das so gut, das musst du natürlich auch flick zurückschreiben, dass er die so gut einbauen kann, dass die direkt funktionieren, dass der Übergang von dritter Liga, von vor zwei Monaten zur erster Liga und jetzt Top-Fußball, dass das so gut funktioniert, dass er sich nie auch drüber beschwert, dass er nicht meckert öffentlich, was andere Trainer vielleicht ein bisschen anders machen. Obwohl er viele Verletzte hat und viele Jungs, dass das trotzdem so gut funktioniert und sie so Leistung abliefern, muss man dem Trainerteam zuschreiben, das ist wirklich gute Arbeit.
Und jetzt habe ich doch noch eine Frage, entschuldige. Aber ist die Zufriedenheit über Hansi Flix auf so einem stabilen Fundament stehend, dass das jetzt auch bleiben würde, wenn man jetzt gegen Bayern und Real verliert?
Das ist halt jetzt die Frage, denn das sind die gradmesser. Das sind jetzt andere Gegner. deswegen bin ich auch wahrscheinlich nicht so euphorisch wie du, weil ich einfach weiß, okay, es ist schön und gut, hier die La Liga-Gegner zu schlagen, die Mallorcas und leganes und Co. Aber Bayern und Real Madrid, das sind andere Kaliber. deswegen bleibe ich vorsichtig optimistisch, um es mal so zu sagen. Aber er hat sich jetzt so viel Kredit erspielt, also der wird nicht in die Kritik geraten, wenn er jetzt irgendwie beide Spieler nicht gewinnen sollte. Denn man weiß ja, es ist ein neues Projekt, es ist eine junge Mannschaft. Wie gesagt, viele, viele Stammspieler waren ja noch gar nicht dabei, können ja die fitness noch gar nicht haben. Frenkie de Jong zum Beispiel hat zwei Kurzeinsätze. Der ist natürlich noch nicht annähernd bei 100 Prozent, geschweige denn überhaupt bei 80. Gar wie vielleicht feierte das Comeback vielleicht noch nicht, muss man ja auch abwarten. Kreuzbandrist, der war zehn Monate verletzt oder so. Von daher hast du da natürlich auch erst recht sehr viel Kredit, selbst wenn die Ergebnisse vielleicht nicht perfekt passen sollten.
Also jetzt geht es erstmal am Sonntag gegen Sevilla und dann kommt eben Mittwoch nächste Woche der FC Bayern in Barcelona und dann am Samstag um 21 Uhr gegen Real Madrid in Madrid. Wir sind sehr gespannt, wie es dann weitergeht und wir sagen Hallo zu Uli Hebel. Schön, dass du da bist, Uli.
Hallo, grüß euch.
Damit bist du jetzt auch offiziell zu sehen und nicht nur für uns. Ab jetzt aufpassen. Jetzt läuft die Kamera. Aber lasst uns mal als nächstes in die Ligue 1 gehen. Ich freue mich ja sehr, dass Michi Postel vom Kicker mal wieder hier ist. Und Michi, du hast uns einen bundesliga-legionär mitgebracht. Als dein Top-Thema. Um wen geht es denn da?
Richtig. Ich würde gern mal die Situation von Kevin Danso heute beleuchten. Er hat ja ein paar Jahre in Augsburg gespielt, ist dann nach Lens gewechselt und hat da in der ersten Saison ein paar Probleme gehabt. Ist dann aber aufgestimmt zu einem wirklich hochklassigen Verteidiger in der Liga A, hat deshalb immer wieder auch das interesse anderer Vereine, vor allem in der Premier League, aus sich gezogen. Er hatte selbst auch gesagt, dass die Premier League schon auch ein Wunschziel von ihm ist. Gewechselt ist er dann am Ende aber nie, unter anderem deshalb, weil Lens natürlich auch international gespielt hat. Innerhalb der Liga A hat er sich aber immer mehr gemausert, war der Abwehrchef, spricht mittlerweile gut französisch auch. In diesem Sommer war es ein bisschen schwierig bei ihm. Er wollte dann unbedingt wechseln. Also Lens hatte mit der AS Rom dann auch einen Abnehmer gefunden. Er war bei Medizincheck und da ist er dann durchgefallen. Er hat danach ein Statement auf seinen sozialen Medienkanälen gepostet. Da ging es vor allem darum, dass er enttäuscht ist, verärgert und auch ein bisschen verwundert, warum das jetzt nicht geklappt hat. Offiziell waren es Herzprobleme. Also die Ärzte der AS Rom haben dann quasi gesagt, der ist nicht spielfähig, zumindest nicht auf dem Niveau. Und hatten ihn dann durchfallen lassen. Er war wie gesagt verärgert, wäre gern gewechselt. Er ist jetzt seit, ich glaube, fast zwei Monaten ist er jetzt raus, hat nicht gespielt, wegen dieser herzgeschichte eben. Aber in dieser Zeit war Raude auch nicht untätig. Er hat mehrere Kliniken aufgesucht, mehrere Fachärzte unter anderem in London und hat sich seine Spielfähigkeit von allen bestätigen lassen.
Aber warum spielt er dann nicht?
Naja, weil es bisher eben noch nicht geklärt war. Bisher war man sich noch nicht sicher, ist da denn wirklich was? Also haben die denn wirklich irgendwas gefunden? Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt auch nicht genau, warum der Wechsel dann nicht geklappt hat. Offiziell sind es wie gesagt diese Herzprobleme, aber da danach niemand was gefunden hat bei ihm, können es natürlich auch andere Gründe geben. Aber das ist reine Spekulation.
Kann ich dann auch kurz was dazu sagen?
Sehr gerne, sehr gerne. Er leuchte mich sehr gerne. Ja und danach war er eben verärgert, hat nicht gespielt bis jetzt. Und jetzt am Wochenende gegen Saint-Sétyen soll es dann so weit sein. Kevin Danso soll zurückkehren. Ironischerweise hat Lens aber in dieser Saison eine sehr starke Abwehr, hat eine der besten in der Liga auch. Da gibt es ein Talent, Kusanov heißt der, der ist schon seit ein paar Jahren dort. Ist glaube ich 20 oder was. Ist ein anderer Typ als Danso, aber ist mit seinen 20 Jahren sehr weit, sehr reif, sehr abgeklärt und der wird seinen Platz jetzt auch nicht kampflos aufgeben. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn er jetzt auf dem Niveau ist der vergangenen Saison, dann wird mittelfristig kein Liga an ihm vorbeiführen. Genau, und warum hat es denn jetzt nicht geklappt, Chris?
Ja, also es ist echt ein bisschen von außen schwierig zu beurteilen, weil klar, in Italien hat dann auch groß die Runde gemacht, dass er sich logisch da alles andere als gut gefühlt hat. Aber der Punkt ist ja, erstens hat er jetzt ja wirklich mehrere Wochen nicht gespielt, also so ganz rund. Schien ja dann wohl doch nicht alles gewesen zu sein, sag ich jetzt mal körperlich. Und zweitens, was sich schon ausschließen kann, ist, dass da bei der Roma womöglich andere geschichten eine Rolle gespielt haben. Weil du hast es ja gesagt, eigentlich war ja alles schon ausverhandelt. Der Transfer war komplett in trockenen Tüchern. Danso wäre sogar der teuerste Innenverteidiger oder Verteidiger der Roma aller Zeiten geworden. Also ich glaube, wir waren bei rund 25 Millionen. Also das waren…
Ich kann gleich sagen, sie waren, glaube ich, 22. Also 22 plus 1. Also ein Jahr.
Genau, so um den Dreh rum. Also es wäre echt ein großes investment der Roma gewesen. Und einer, der mindestens gleich enttäuscht war, wie Danso, dass es nicht geklappt hat, war der Rossi. Damals noch der Trainer, weil der Rossi wollte ihn unbedingt, hat genau ihn so quasi als, ja, den Innenverteidiger-Typ auserkoren, den er gebraucht hätte, den er sich gewünscht hätte. Und dementsprechend– klar, ich habe jetzt keine Interna, aber ich tue mich schwer daraus zu stricken, dass die Roma da irgendwie noch einen Ausweg gesucht hat, um aus der Nummer rauszukommen. Also, es muss wohl, man muss vielleicht kurz zur Einordnung sagen, in Italien gab es in den letzten Jahren jetzt immer wieder Fälle, wo bei Medizinchecks wirklich sehr genau hingeschaut wurde. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich noch ein paar Patrick Schick, bevor er auch nach Leverkusen kam. Da gab es auch, der war eigentlich schon auf dem Sprung zu Juve, ist dann eigentlich auch beim Medizincheck durchgefallen. Also da ist eine gewisse Sensibilität da und ich glaube nicht, die Roma-Ärzte haben jetzt nicht festgestellt, dass er nicht spielfähig ist, sondern ich glaube, die Roma-Ärzte haben dann wahrscheinlich klar gemacht, oh, pass mal auf, da ist was am Herz, was es vielleicht noch zu klären gibt. Und dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass logisch auch das investment da eine Rolle gespielt hat, dass man sich dann gesagt hat, oh, pass mal auf, das ist schon viel Geld, gerade für einen Innenverteidiger. Und wenn wir uns da nicht ganz, ganz sicher sind, dann ja, lassen wir das Ganze vielleicht dann doch bleiben. Also das war so ein bisschen die Lage in Rom. Also der Rossi, wie gesagt, war selbst danach auf den pressekonferenzen, hat ihn sogar mehrfach noch namentlich genannt, obwohl er ja kein Romerspieler mehr war oder überhaupt nie war. Und das hat eigentlich schon zu verstehen geben, dass der Rossi sehr auf ihn gebaut hat und dementsprechend, ja, glaube ich, war das wirklich eine medizinische geschichte, die sich jetzt ja auch ein paar Wochen hingezogen hat. Und ja, wünschen wir ihm, dass das jetzt wirklich keine große Rolle mehr spielt. Aber ich würde wirklich aus Romas Sicht eigentlich, glaube ich nicht, dass da irgendwie so von wegen, oh mein Gott, was haben wir da für einen Transfer abgeschlossen, lass uns da nochmal vom Zug abspringen. Also das Gefühl hatte ich in Rom überhaupt nicht.
Ja, er war ja auch, er war halt in Betreuung beim ÖFB erst mal und bei La Liga und es sind zwei natürlich voneinander unabhängige Abteilungen, die das beide nicht feststellen konnten. Das hat dann im Grunde die Spekulation aus französischer Sicht natürlich hervorgerufen. Aber im Endeffekt ist es ja auch nachvollziehbar, wenn du dann als Verein so viel Geld hinblättern willst und dann eben was findest, gerade am Herzen. Also ich meine, so eine Narbe entsteht ja schnell, wenn du eine Herzmuskelentzündung verschläfst oder was, dann hast du direkt eine Narbe. Und ich glaube, so was war es dann auch. Also so ein Detail, das bei ihm eben nicht gepasst hat. Und ja, das haben sie jetzt offiziell zumindest ausgeräumt. diese Narbe, diesen Fehler, dieses Problem am Herzen. Genau, und deswegen soll er jetzt gegen Samtseltieren wieder zurückkehren.
Das zeigt halt noch einen weiteren Aspekt, den man da ganz gut aufweisen kann. Nämlich die Problematik, dass nicht zuletzt durch Transferjournalismus, wie wir über jeden Schritt bei solchen Transfers informiert sind, und gleichzeitig aber der Medizincheck in den Kern eines Leistungssportlers reingeht. Und das kann ja rufschädigend sein. Also sagen wir jetzt einfach mal Kevin Danso hätte spielen können. Es gab zwar Anlass zu Vorsicht, aber er hätte jetzt die ganzen zwei Monate spielen können. Dann ist ihm ja irre ein Schaden zugefügt worden, dadurch, dass das öffentlich geworden ist. Und dadurch, dass wir uns aber auch alle das Recht rausnehmen, eben über die gesundheit von Spielern informiert zu werden. Und dass dann eben nicht gesagt wird, der Transfer kommt nicht zustande. Zu den Gründen äußern wir uns nicht, sondern dass gesagt wird, es wäre auch nicht anders gegangen, weil alle waren informiert und so weiter. Das hat man ja alles lesen können, quasi in den sozialen Netzwerken. Aber dann ist quasi klar, er ist durch den Medizin-Check gefallen. Und relativ schnell wird dann irgendwann auch publik, wegen des Herzens. Und das ist ja schon aus Sicht der Spieler eine krasse Nummer. Wenn du überlegst, er hat jetzt zwei Monate seinen Beruf nicht ausüben können. Und ein anderer Wechsel wäre ja noch möglich gewesen. Der ist ganz sicher auch deshalb nicht zustande gekommen. Alle lassen jetzt erstmal die Finger von Kevin Danzo. Da können wir jetzt alle nichts dran ändern. Wahrscheinlich sind wir uns da auch alle einig. Aber es ist schon interessant, dass das auch so ein Auswuchs ist, der etwas fiebrigen Berichterstattung über Transfers. Bei Palinja hätte das ähnlich sein können zum Beispiel. Stellt euch mal vor, der Palinja-Wechsel zu Bayern hätte nicht geklappt und irgendjemand hätte falschlicherweise gesagt, ja hier liegt er am Herzen oder irgendwie sowas. Und wir haben das gefunden. Und dann ist es schon interessant, wie das die Spieler betrifft. Und das vergisst man auch, glaube ich, in unserer Arbeit oft.
Ja, es ist auch ein wahnsinnig sensibler Bereich, genau wie du es sagst. Also erstens ein sehr persönlicher Bereich, weil es ja die eigene gesundheit betrifft. Dann Herzen ist logischerweise noch mal, glaube ich, was, wo bei vielen dann ja noch mal die Augen größer werden. Und ich habe das Ganze dann auch medial verfolgt. Es gab ja auch in den Wochen danach gab es zum Beispiel Gerüchte, wonach es sich einer OP unterziehen müsste. Und das wurde dann zum Beispiel kam auch alles gar nicht zum Stande. Also ich gebe da Max völlig recht. Das ist schon ein Bereich, wo, glaube ich, der ganze Medien-Tross auch ein bisschen mehr Vorsicht walten lassen sollte.
Definitiv vor allem, weil er dann ja auch alles getan hat, um das zu widerlegen. Also er ist ja anscheinend in mehrere Länder geflogen und hat sich von unabhängigen Experten dann ihr Urteil geben lassen. Und wenn du da nicht spielen kannst, dann ist es mental ja auch belastend und du stehst wahrscheinlich unter großem Druck, wenn du halt in der weltgeschichte rumfliegst und denkst, da irgendwas beweisen zu müssen, was du vorher gar nicht wusstest. Wobei, wie gesagt, so eine Narbe entsteht schnell. Also ich mag mal behaupten, dass das auch Amateursportler, die halt was verschleppen, die ihre Symptome nicht ganz wahrnehmen, dann haben sie halt so eine Narbe am Herzmuskel. Und dann ist die halt da, die... Manchmal ist es so, dass sie ihr Leben lang nicht merken. Manchmal ist es dann so, dass das zu einer Entzündung führt. Aber genau, das ist halt in dem Fall, es ist kein Kreuzbandriss. Also es ist nichts offensichtlich wahrnehmbar schlimmes. Aber es kann zu was Schlimmem werden.
Schauen wir doch, ob er jetzt dann spielt gegen Saint Etienne. Außerdem kann man in diesem Segment noch gut sagen, Ligatour-Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen mehr, denn ihr habt es noch auf dem Schirm, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, über Kusanoff, da haben wir doch schon mal gesprochen, am 12. Oktober 2023. Ich habe noch mal nachgeguckt. Damals hatte nämlich David uns alle in der Runde gefragt, welche usbekischen Nationalspieler schon mal in den entsprechenden Ligen gespielt haben. Das war eine sehr lustige Diskussion damals. Also könnt ihr noch mal nachhören, da habt ihr es zum ersten Mal gehört. Da kommt jemand aus Usbekistan und der spielt eine gute Rolle bei La Liga. Jetzt, wenn wir Uli Hebel in der Runde haben. Uli, deine Themen kenne ich noch nicht. Sprechen wir über Klubfußball oder sprechen wir über ein Nationalteam? Fände ich nicht schlimm.
Wie immer, wie immer darfst du es dir aussuchen. Ich bin präpariert für alles. Ich kann dir zu allen 20 Teams in der Premier League was sagen. Ich kann aber auch gerne dir Auskunft geben, soweit ich was weiß über das Nationalteam.
Das ist selbstverständlich das dominante Thema. Ich weiß nicht, wie es die anderen sehen. Ich möchte unbedingt auch die Meinung der anderen hören. Wir müssen über Thomas Tuchel als neuen englischen Nationaltrainer sprechen, weil Uli das hat ja auch tatsächlich eine große Dimension. Ein deutscher Trainer auf dem englischen Nationaltrainerstuhl. Das waren die ersten Reaktionen der Medien. Das war schon unterschiedlich zu entnehmen.
Generell gab es ja eh die Diskussion in England, ähnlich wie in Deutschland, als Louis van Gaal zum Beispiel mal sich selbst ins gespräch gebracht hat oder ins gespräch gebracht worden ist. In Deutschland, ob es überhaupt möglich sei, dass ein Ausländer das mache, jetzt ist der Unterschied in England, dass es das ja schon gab, in Capello und in Ericsson vor 15, 20 Jahren. Das heißt, es ist also nicht mehr ganz so neu und nicht mehr total anders, aber alle Boulevard-Medien haben unisono das eine Thema gespielt, kann das mit einem Deutschen gut sein bei den Engländern. Weil diese Rivalität, so nenne ich es jetzt mal, die ist vor allen Dingen von den Engländern gegenüber den Deutschen schon mit etwas mehr Abneigung versehen, als jetzt vielleicht andersrum. Und da gab es schon noch mal Fragezeichen. Heißt aber auch, so muss man die englischen Medien ja auch mal lesen, dass es nicht anderweitig viele Kritikpunkte gab. Ich glaube, das kann man auch als positiv verzeichnen, wenn man möchte, weil jeder wusste, das wird natürlich emotional eine Diskussion hervorrufen, ob ein Deutscher geht oder nicht. Aber ja, es ist ein Thema gewesen und es ist es immer noch. Also in aller Berichterstattung ist das eigentlich im Grunde die Liedzeile der deutsche Macht.
Wer sich mehr zu diesem Konflikt im Fußball zwischen Deutschland und England interessiert, der kann sehr gerne das sehr gute Buch von Hendrik dazu lesen. Hendrik Buch heißt da, we call it a Klassiker. Ich werde es nochmal in den Show notes verlinken. Aber jetzt jenseits eben von dieser Dimension. Uli, alle, die dir nicht auf TikTok folgen, was natürlich zu verurteilen ist, folgt Uli auf TikTok. Diejenigen wissen es nämlich schon. Ich auch. Was denkst du denn über diesen Transfer?
Ich finde es sehr, sehr gut, sehr, sehr clever, sehr, sehr konsequent und wahrscheinlich die beste Entscheidung, die die DFRI je getroffen hat. Und da waren nicht so viele zwar gute dabei, aber es wurde besser und besser in den letzten Jahren. Legt einfach ganz, ganz klar da dran. Ich glaube, die FA hat probiert, ob das mit Lee Carsley funktionieren würde. Also das wäre dann die komplette Southgate-Kopie gewesen, was die Lösung betrifft. Du holst einen aus der eigenen U21, jemanden, der lange im Verband ist, jemand, der auf eine Art und Weise spricht, der positiv ist, der in dem Fall jetzt eine gewisse Idee von Fußball hat. Aber sie haben aller spätestens beim Griechenland-Länderspiel, glaube ich, gemerkt, nee, läuft nicht. Und dann sind sie noch mal etwas intensiver geworden in der Suche und haben aber jemanden geholt, den sie jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen plötzlich präsentiert bekommen haben, sondern den haben sie schon kontaktiert. Das war ja eine sehr gute Quelle, bevor er bei den Bayern angefangen hat. Das heißt, die grundsätzliche Bereitschaft Tuchels ist schon mal abgeklopft worden, ob er sich überhaupt einen Nationaltrainer vorstellen könnte und ob er sich überhaupt England vorstellen könnte. Und weil Castle nicht funktioniert hat als interne Lösung und weil, glaube ich, keine englische Lösung darstellbar war, also die einzige, die, glaube ich, alle sofort gefressen hätten, wäre Eddie Hau von Newcastle gewesen, der es auch eines tages werden wird. Da muss man sich nichts vormachen. Der hat ja immer mal so ganz leicht, minimal geflirtet. Das ist aber weniger und weniger geworden in den letzten Wochen, weil er, glaube ich, weiß, dass Newcastle ihn a. nicht gehen lässt und b. seine Aktien auch nicht so hoch sind, wie sie schon mal waren. Und dann könnte man theoretisch durchgehen, welche englischen Trainer würden euch überhaupt noch einfallen. Das ist dann gleich ein strukturelles Problem. Das Verband ist auch, dass sie angehen sollten, Training-Ausbildung und Kosten für Training-Ausbildung vor allen Dingen. Aber die einzig möglichen Lösungen wären noch gewesen. Dann neben Eddie Hau vielleicht Graham Potter, dessen Aktien ähnlich wenig hoch sind. Und in der aktuellen Phase, glaube ich, eher nach Southgate gewirkt hätte, als nach Tuchel. Und dann gäbe es noch zwei, drei Leute, die irgendwo im Job sind. Gary O'Neill ist gerade letzter. Das wird zum Backup-Thema gewesen mit den wolves. Den habe ich immer mal reingeworfen, hätte ich mir gut vorstellen können. Das heißt, das machst du als FA-Moment auch nicht. Und dann gäbe es noch so etwas wie ehemaliger Nationalspieler Michael Carrick von middlesbrough, der aber noch nie ein Premier League-Spiel gecoacht hat als Beispiel. Und wenn sie wirklich gehandelt hätten wie vor 20 Jahren, dann hätten sie wahrscheinlich Rain Rooney gefragt, ob du was machst oder irgendwie irgendwas dergleichen. Sodass ich eigentlich nach einem Ausschlussprinzip relativ schnell dazu komme, jetzt habt ihr jemanden, der spricht Englisch, der kennt sich aus in England, da gibt es keinerlei Diskussionen über dessen fachliche Kenntnisse, über auch seine Aura. Ja, das ist eigentlich relativ logisch.
Ich habe viele Gedanken dazu, aber ich will die anderen mal reinhören. Wer am schnellsten ist, darf die erste Meinung abgeben. Wie denkt ihr denn über diesen Transfer oder diese Verpflichtung?
Ich finde es eine überraschend gute Verpflichtung oder Entscheidung tatsächlich. Ich bin dabei Uli. Ich halte auch viel von Tuchel. Jetzt hat er bei Bayern natürlich nicht ganz so optimal funktioniert, wie er erwartet. Die wollten ja hinten raus das Triple gewinnen und dann wurde es eher wenig damit. Also auch da hatte ich mir schon mehr von ihm erwartet, aber nichtsdestotrotz, und er hat keine Nationaltrainer-Erfahrung, ist ja trotzdem dann ein anderes Arbeiten. Also da muss man ja auch abwarten, wie gut er das für sich selbst dann hinbekommt. Aber ich bin da sehr angetan von, ich sage fast schon leider, Klammeraufklammer zu, also ich finde das eine hervorragende Wahl für den englischen Verband, ja, definitiv.
Vor allem, du sprichst dich ja gerade an, als Nationaltrainer hast du nicht täglich mit deinen Bossen zu tun, du hast nicht täglich mit deinen Spielern zu tun. diese Ereibereien, die ihm ja auch in München zu verhängnis wurden, die sind auf täglicher Basis in einem Verband nicht gegeben. Das heißt, das kann sogar ein Vorteil für ihn sein. Außerdem wählt er die Spieler selber aus, die er holt. Wenn er jetzt einen Wunschspieler hat, gibt es keinen Boss, der ihm den verwehren kann. Und ich glaube auch, dass in England das Thema Chelsea, die ja damals– im Grunde war es ein Trümmerhaufen– zu dem Zeitpunkt auch, als er die übernommen hat, war das 2021 oder was? Naja, jedenfalls hat er die übernommen und hat die doch noch auf Platz 4 und zum Champions-League-Sieg geführt, mit einer klaren Struktur, mit klaren Ansagen. Ich glaube, davon kann er auch noch zähren. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, inwiefern das Scheitern bei Bayern dann das große Thema in England ist. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der Champions-League-Sieg und das Auf-Vordermann-Bringen von Chelsea noch eher in den Köpfen ist als diese Zeit in München. Das heißt, er hat eine Reputation, er hat einen Ruf, von dem er noch zähren kann. Ich glaube auch, dass das ein Vorteil sein kann für ihn.
Also ich fand es überhaupt nicht überraschend, muss ich sagen. So wie Uli das jetzt ja quasi beschrieben hat, war vielleicht die Frage, wann so was dann kommen kann, quasi der Zeitpunkt, das vielleicht. Aber dass er es werden würde oder werden könnte, fand ich jetzt sehr stringent. Ich meine, er hat ja nie einen Hedl rausgemacht, dass seine Beziehung zum englischen Fußball eine sehr enge ist. Und dementsprechend glaube ich, nimmt er das auch als sehr große Ehre wahr. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich schon sehr gespannt. Ich meine, wir haben oft übers Ausgelt geredet und es gibt, glaube ich, genügend Kritikpunkte. Aber wenn ich mir so anschaue, wie weiter mit den Mannschaften zuletzt bei den Turnieren gekommen ist, dann würde ich mal sagen, das musst du dann als Tuchel auch erst mal hinbekommen. deswegen glaube ich, wird halt alles daran gemessen werden, wie das Ganze läuft. Weil, jetzt blöde Sache, lasst den im Achtelfinale und Viertelfinale vom nächsten großen Turnier ausscheiden. Dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie viel die Freude haben, wenn es dann eben heißt, das hat der Deutsche jetzt quasi hinbekommen. Aber das ist ja alles zukunftsbesitz.
Ja, aber ich finde, das ist schon ein interessanter Punkt. Und deswegen bin ich nämlich kritischer dieser Verpflichtung, obwohl ja alles stimmt, was Uli sagt. Thomas Tuchel war gerade die beste von gar nicht so vielen Alternativen. Aber das Problem waren doch nie die Ergebnisse. Das Problem war doch immer, wie die Ergebnisse erzielt wurden. Und trauen wir Thomas Tuchel zu, dass die Art und Weise, wie Ergebnisse erzielt werden, jetzt so nennenswert besser wird, dass man eben auch, sollte man dann mal, Achtelfinale, Viertelfinale, Halbfinale rausfliegen, dass man dann trotzdem damit zufrieden ist. Und das kann natürlich sein. Ich würde Thomas Tuchel auch nicht unrecht tun. Aber beim FC Bayern sehen, haben wir schon etwas anderes gesehen, unter anderen Umständen. deswegen muss man da sehr vorsichtig sein, jetzt nicht zu sagen, das wird sich sofort setzen. Aber dahingehend finde ich diese Entscheidung, ich weiß nicht, wie du es siehst, Uli, dann wiederum nicht besonders mutig, von der FA Thomas Tuchel zu nehmen.
Ne, mutig ist sie nicht. Das ist Win-Now-Modus jetzt. Also ich glaube, die ganz klare Aufgabe ist, du wirst gefälligst Weltmeister 2026 und ich würde aber auch tippen, dass das dann in Schimpf und Schande auseinanderginge, wenn es nicht klappt, beiderseitig möglich. Das Ganze hat mehrere Dimensionen. Man kann ja auch Tuchels Perspektive mit reinnehmen. Ich treffe den hier ganz oft, der läuft hier in der Nachbarschaft rum, ist ja ziemlich– also, ist immer beim selben Bäcker und so weiter. Der wirkt sehr, sehr glücklich mit seinem Leben. Und ich glaube, dass der das hier in München gar nicht aufgeben wollte. Und das macht es jetzt so, ich habe gestern kurz mit einem englischen Kollegen gesprochen, der gesagt hat, das wusste ich so gar nicht. Dann ist alles total sinnvoll. Er hat gesagt, das muss er mir nochmal ganz genau erzählen, was da im Vertrag drinsteht. Die Zeit hatte ich jetzt noch nicht, aber es scheint so zu sein, dass hat er sich das schon auch reinschreiben lassen, dass er Part-Time Deutscher weiterhin sein darf sozusagen. Wer Tuchel aber kennt, weiß, dass er das Ganze sehr ehrgeizig angehen wird. Ich denke, es gibt verschiedene Lösungen, warum das für ihn clever ist. Einmal die private, einmal die Situation, dass er jetzt gar nicht fordern kann. Also es gibt ja nicht irgendwie die Forderung, verpflichte mir den, verpflichte mir den, ich brauche dies, ich brauche das. Sondern du hast einen gewissen Spielerpool. Und dieser Spielerpool spielt ja zu 80% bei absoluten Elite-Managern. Ich würde sogar fast auf 90% gehen. Und ich glaube, Tuchel ist in der Lage, den Spielern einfach nur die Freiheit zu geben, dass sie nur die Automatismen aus dem Verein mitnehmen müssen. Das scheint ja erstmal ein relativ leichter Job zu sein. Und dann ist er jemand, und das, was Michi gesagt hat, ist ja schon korrekt. Er ist jemand, der den allerhöchsten Ruf genießt, was nicht ganz unwichtig ist in England. Auch bei Gegnern, die er geschlagen hat. Und das, glaube ich, wird auch dazu führen, dass der, ähnlich wie Southgate, ja hart den großen respekt genießen wird innerhalb der Mannschaft. Die Frage ist ehrlicherweise innerhalb des verbandes, weil das war ja eine der größten Errungenschaften southgates, dass er seinen eigenen Einfluss maximiert und den Einfluss anderer in der FA minimiert hat. deswegen konnte der so lange so wirken, wie er wollte und war eigentlich der Einzige, der nach außen gesprochen hat. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, inwiefern Tuchel das machen will, dass er es macht und machen kann, wissen wir aus München. Das wissen wir auch aus Paris, da hat er ja auch seine eigene Wahrheit gesagt. Aber inwiefern er das als englischer Nationaltrainer auch machen kann und aber auch möchte im Umgang mit der presse, da bin ich noch sehr gespannt. Aber klar, wir wissen alle nicht, wie der Nationaltrainer Thomas Tuchel funktioniert. Ob ihm das nicht irgendwann zu langweilig wird, ob er nicht vielleicht zu viel will, so ähnlich wie Nagelsmann ja auch, dass er dann unterm Strich irgendwann gesagt hat, naja gut, dann muss ich halt jetzt hier einfach eine etwas sicherere, leichter verständliche Variante einziehen. Klar, alles möglich, dass er da vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel diskutieren will, das wissen wir alle nicht. Aber ich würde tippen, dass Tuchel völlig in der Lage ist, das zu machen. Und hat sich auch mit Anthony Barry wieder seinen absoluten Vertrauten geholt. Ich habe nichts von Scholt Löw gelesen im Übrigen. Dann können wir schon mal die Klammer aufmachen und den beide der bundesliga begrüßen, Klammer zu, weil ich glaube, das heißt dann was, wenn dem so ist. Aber ich habe, egal von welcher Seite ich es sehe, ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass es scheitert, außer eben, wenn es im Halbfinale rausgeht. Und das kann ja immer passieren. Und dann werden die beiden Parteien halt ungut zueinander. Aber trotzdem, nach Machbarkeit betrachtet, sie haben auch mit Goldiola gesprochen bei der FA. Der hat sich sogar angehört. Das ist sicherlich auch nicht darstellbar gewesen. Und zumindest nicht in der Schnelligkeit darstellbar gewesen. Da gibt es ja auch noch Paperwork zu tun, ob derjenige mit Brexit und so weiter Arbeitsgenehmigungen bekommt. Das hängt ja auch noch mit zusammen, dass Tuchel jetzt nicht sofort anfangen kann. Oder schon in der nächsten Länderspielpause. Und der wird wahrscheinlich auch gesagt haben, Goldiola ja, aber wenn, dann ab 26. Geht also auch nicht. Und dann, wen willst du nehmen? Bei wem gäbe es keine Red Flags? Ich glaube, bei Tuchel gibt es die wenigsten.
Wir schauen es uns sehr genau an. Und zu dem Thema der Wertschätzung in Deutschland versus in der Premier League beziehungsweise in England werde ich euch einen Tweet verlinken von Archie Rintard. Der hat nämlich im Januar genau darüber mit Thomas Tuchel gesprochen. Und die Antwort von Thomas Tuchel ist sehr eindeutig. Ja, ich werde dort mehr wertgeschätzt.
Ich habe übrigens jeden einzelnen Deutschen gefragt, der mal in England gespielt hat oder gearbeitet hat. Also sei es Scout, Spieler, Trainer, und die sagen alle, ja, und die Sonne ging ganz schnell, ja, es ist ganz was anderes.
Ja, verrückt. War auch zu merken, letztes dazu, als Arsenal bei Bayern gespielt hat, ist Thomas Tuchel mit den Fragen der englischen Kolleginnen und Kollegen anders umgegangen als mit den deutschen Fragen. Die haben ihn einfachste taktische Fragen gestellt und haben ganz lange Erklärungen bekommen. Und ich habe ihm nur taktische Fragen gestellt und habe mehrmals das Gleiche quasi gehört und dann dachte ich mir, warum möchtest du es mir denn nicht sagen, aber egal. Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Bemerkenswert ist übrigens dann doch der Widerspruch, denn der Boulevard ist ja nicht so happy, der German in Versaillen auch. Also er wird mehr wertgeschätzt, ja, aber von den Boulevard-Medien, naja.
Das ist das geschäftsmodell, würde ich sagen. Das ist ein allererster Linie geschäftsmodell. Weil du weißt, und wie gesagt, die Diskussion können wir jetzt führen. Ich kann euch jetzt ja alle fragen. Wir sind ja gut, Christian, nicht. Aber wenn ich Christian fragen würde, was würdest du sagen, wenn, keine Ahnung, Sine Dinsi dann italienischer Nationaltrainer werden würde? Oder bei uns, Van Raal oder– ich wahrscheinlich ist in Deutschland das Sinnvollste, Niederländer zu nehmen, wie zum Beispiel Van Raal oder meinetwegen Ronald Koeman. Also jetzt mal unabhängig von der fachlichen Eignung. Aber wie wird es uns damit gehen, wenn ein Nicht-Deutscher zum ersten Mal dann in der geschichte des verbandes in der Nationalmannschaft übernähme?
Aber warum soll das so ein Thema sein?
Mir ist es wurscht. Das ist nicht mein Problem. Aber ich glaube, dass du bei 90% der Deutschen eine andere Antwort hättest.
Ja, okay, das kann sein. Lassen wir es so stehen und schauen es uns genau an. Auf jeden Fall schön, dass wir heute aufzeichnen und nicht vorgestern. Dann hätte dieses Thema nämlich ein bisschen auf sich warten müssen. Wir wollen aber noch in die Serie A blicken. Also wir kommen jetzt zurück zum Clubfußball. Christian, was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Ja, ich glaube, es bietet sich an, mal einen Blick auf Milan zu werfen. Da ist einiges los die letzten Wochen schon, die ganze junge Saison. Fangen wir mal an mit einer kleinen Einordnung. Also Milan hat ja von Seca neu geholt im Sommer. Neuer Trainer, Nachfolger von Piolli, nachdem Piolli Milan zum Meister gemacht hat, Milan ins Champions League-Halbfinale geführt hat, Milan letztes Jahr auf Platz 2 geführt hat. Aber irgendwie war dann der Punkt erreicht, dass man gesagt hat, man will was neues. Und zu von Seca muss man Anfangs sagen, das war nicht die erste Wahl. Eigentlich war Lopetegui der Mann, der hätte kommen sollen. Aber da gab es ziemlich vehemente fan-proteste und da hat sich dann die Klubführung wirklich ausbremsen lassen. Hat Lopetegui es sozusagen nicht fix gemacht und hat jetzt von Seca gebracht. Und zu von Seca, das war dann am Anfang so holprig, dass er vor wenigen Wochen, kurz vorm Derby gegen Inter, eigentlich schon sehr angezählt war. Es gab das Derby gegen Inter und ich sage mal so, hätte Milan das verloren, dann wäre es gut möglich gewesen, dass das Kapitel von Seca schon zu Ende gewesen wäre. Er hat das Spiel aber gewonnen, das Derby gegen Inter gewonnen, hat vier Tage später dann auch gegen Lecce nachgelegt, ein 3-0-Sieg und dementsprechend war dann vielleicht so ein bisschen von außen der Eindruck da, okay, jetzt hat er seine erste große Prüfung bestanden, hat wirklich gegen viele Widerstände sozusagen erfolgreich angekämpft und ist jetzt vielleicht angekommen, aber es ging wieder sehr schnell ein bisschen in die andere Richtung. Jetzt kam das Leverkusen-Spiel in der Champions League, das haben sie 1-0 verloren, nachdem sie eine Stunde lang nicht wirklich interesse hatten, da mitzuspielen. Die letzte halbe Stunde war gut, aber eine Stunde lang war das nicht das, was sie sich vorstellen. Und haben jetzt auch vor der Länderspielpause in Florenz verloren, 1 zu 2, und dementsprechend ist es gleich schon wieder ein bisschen unruhig geworden. Also was ich damit sagen will, es ist wirklich eine gewisse Unruhe bei Milan Spürper. Die liegt zum einen daran, dass jetzt von Seca nicht der große, starke Mann quasi ist, der vielleicht so etwas auch ein bisschen abfedert. Also es ist ganz klar, als in Italien macht immer mehr der Begriff, den wird Uli wahrscheinlich gut kennen, er ist sein idealer yes-man, also einer, den ein Club halt holt, der sich dann nicht weiß Gott, wie groß sind die Transfers mit einmischt, sondern der quasi die Clubführung machen lässt und dann mit dem Material, was er da eben hat, versucht, das bestmögliche rauszuholen.
Ist es dann der Signore Si auf Italienisch?
Ja, kann ich dir leider nicht bestätigen, dass das gibt. Aber wer weiß, Max, vielleicht schaffen wir es ja noch, das ins Italienisch einzubauen.
Er ist auch keiner, merkste, oder? Er sagt auch nein.
Einzubauen quasi, genau. Also ich finde, man muss jetzt dann noch zwei Aspekte trennen. Bleiben wir erstmal beim Fußballerischen, bei dem, was er von Seca zu verantworten hat. Er hat diesen Turn-Out im Derby durch eine sehr mutige Art und Weise geschafft. Er hat nämlich auf quasi ein 4-2-4 umgestellt. Also er hat auf Doppelspitze umgestellt, Morata plus Abraham und dazu als Außen Leao und Pulisic. Und wenn Leao und Pulisic deine Außen sind, dann würde ich jetzt weniger von 4-4-2 sprechen, sondern schon eher von 4-2-4. Das hat sich gegen ihn da bezahlt gemacht. Aber darin, und darin hat er jetzt so ein bisschen sein System gefunden, wo er das Gefühl hat, damit kämpfe ich jetzt gegen all diese Widerstände an. Das Problem ist, der Kader, den er zur Verfügung hat, lässt so ein System eigentlich über einen langen Zeitraum kaum zu. Das fängt zum einen damit an, dass er hinter Morata und Abrams so gut wie keinen Backups hat, um diese zwei Mittelstürmerrollen zu besetzen. Die nächsten sind Okafor und Jovic. Jovic spielt überhaupt keine Rolle mehr. Und Okafor ist jetzt halt auch nicht der Spielertyp, der dann vielleicht einen Abram oder Morata beerben könnte. Er kann von der Bank kaum etwas bringen. Die Außen, also Leão und Bülisic, sind sehr klar 1a Qualität. Wenn er die aber sozusagen auswechseln will, dann hat er auch Okafor oder chukwese. Da ist der Leistungsabfall auch sehr groß. In der heutigen Zeit wissen wir immer mehr mit den fünf Wechseln, gerade für Top-Teams, geht es auch oft darum, die Spiele in der zweiten Hälfte vielleicht über die Wechsel noch mal zu beleben. Und sprich, wenn er mit allen vier seinen Offensiven anfängt, mit seinen Klasseleuten, sage ich mal, dann ist das, was von der Bank kommt, einfach qualitativ nicht mehr so gut. Loftus Chiek ist einer, den könntest du vielleicht so ein bisschen in diese Morata-Rolle rein drücken, auch wenn Loftus Chiek alles andere als Morata ist. Das ist mir schon klar. Aber Morata spielt ja auch mehr so eine hängende Spitze, die ihm auch sehr wahnsinnig fleißig gegen den Ball arbeitet, sehr gut im pressing ist, sehr laufstark. Aber da sind wir halt wieder beim Thema sehr laufintensiv. Milan spielt alle drei Tage. Milan hat die ersten zwei Spiele in der Champions League verloren. Also muss da jetzt auch in die Bütte kommen, braucht Punkte. Dementsprechend ist sowas, glaube ich, über die ganze Zone einfach nicht darstellbar. Plus der entscheidende Punkt, da weiß der Michi sicher auch viel darüber, vor Fahner, der ja im Sommer kam zu Milan, der ist wirklich jetzt dieser entscheidende Mann auf der Doppel-Sechs, der halt gegen den Ball hat. Es war genau der Spielertyp, der Milan gefehlt hat. Also der Löcher nach hinten schließt, dass der einfach diese Dynamik auch mitbringt. Und vor Fahner läuft im Moment jetzt schon für zwei, manchmal für drei. Und ich sage mal so, ich glaube auch nicht, dass der das durchstehen kann quasi ohne adäquaten Ersatz. Denn auch da ist die Bank ziemlich kurz. Der einzige Benazir, der das vielleicht könnte, der fällt monatelang aus. Und dann hast du im Loftus Cheek. Loftus Cheeks brauchst du im 4-2-4 nicht auf der Doppel-Sechs bringen. Das wird dir nicht die Absicherung geben. Und dann ist halt eben Reinders da, der das logisch auch sehr gut macht, aber halt auch mehr den Blick nach vorne richtet, sozusagen. Also was ich damit sagen will, ist, von Seca hat jetzt ein bisschen sein Schicksal damit verknüpft, mit einer sehr offensiven Ausrichtung, wo aber viele, und ich zähle mich dazu, sehr skeptisch sind, ob du das wirklich über einen sehr langen Zeitraum, über eine lange Saison einfach durchstehen kannst. Und dazu kommen auch, muss man auch noch kurz sagen, atmosphärische Probleme. Léo und Theo Hernandez, also mit die zwei wichtigsten, spielerisch wichtigsten in der Mannschaft, haben sich schon ein, zwei Aussetzer in dieser Saison gegönnt. Im Spiel gegen Lazio bei einem Cooling Break, wo sich die ganze Mannschaft versammelt hat, sind die ziemlich desinteressiert am Seitenrand gestanden, haben sich nicht zu allen anderen zugestellt. Das hat für einen riesen Alarm gesorgt. Also damit zeigt man halt, dass Léo und Theo, die eigentlich auch Führungsspieler sein sollen, müssen, aber dann doch oft sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt sind und jetzt nicht unbedingt diesen Führungsanspruch, glaube ich, gerecht werden können, in so eine große Mannschaft zu führen. Und jetzt die jüngste geschichte, deswegen finde ich, passt es jetzt auch ganz gut, obwohl das Spiel ja vor der Länderspielpause war. Milan verliert in Florenz 2 zu 1, verschießt dabei zwei Elfmeter. Den ersten verschießt Léo Hernandez, den zweiten verschießt Abraham. Und nach dem Spiel stellt sich von Seca hin, das ist meiner Meinung nach auch nicht ganz clever, kommunikativ, und sagt, die waren beide nicht meine Elfmeterschützen, meine Elfmeterschütze ist eigentlich biulisig. Und gibt damit quasi zu verstehen, dass die Mannschaft selbst entschieden hat, wer die Elfmeter schießt und sie dann auch noch verschießt. Sinnbildlich war wirklich, muss man dazu wissen, der erste Elfmeter war kurz vor der Halbzeit. Also von Seca hatte in der Halbzeit noch mal Zeit, das Thema anzusprechen, die kommen wieder aufs Feld, 5 Minuten, zweite Hälfte sind gespielt, Elfmeter. Und nicht mal da kommt Puljusic an den Punkt, sondern Tomori schnappt sich den Ball und drückt ihn seinem besten Kumpel Abraham in die Hand. Die zwei sind ja große buddies aus Chelsea-Zeiten. Abraham geht hin und verschießt. Also was ich damit sagen will, ist von Seca, das Thema wäre ja gar nicht groß öffentlich aufgekommen. Wir wissen ja alle nicht groß, die Hierarchien. Die waren davor nicht thematisiert. Aber nach dem Spiel stellt sich von Seca hin, sagt es und zeigt damit, dass die Mannschaft in Teilen halt macht, was sie will und nicht unbedingt das, was der Trainer will. Und das hat seine Position logisch wieder geschwächt. Also es ist ein sehr fragiles Konstrukt, Milan momentan. Man muss das jetzt einhauen. In der Liga haben sie elf Punkte, sind nur drei Punkte hinter Juve und Inter. Also da ist jetzt noch nicht viel passiert. Auch in der Champions League, glaube ich, obwohl sie die ersten zwei Spiele verloren haben, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass sie in den nächsten sechs Spielen noch ihre acht oder neun Punkte holen, um da unter die Top 24 zu kommen. Aber es zeigt halt einfach, dass das sehr fragil ist. Und man hat das Gefühl, beim nächsten Unentschieden, bei der nächsten Niederlage wird von Seke halt schon wieder angezählt. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein Zustand, der nicht so gut ist, vielleicht auch mittel- und langfristig.
Ist in Argentinien nicht ein Trainer zurückgetreten, weil die Spieler nicht die Elfmeter-Reihenfolge einhielten und machten, was sie wollten? Ich glaube, ich habe die Woche etwas dazu gelesen.
Ja, also so ist es. Kommt es jetzt nicht. Die Vereinsführung hat von Seke jetzt wieder demonstrativ den Rücken gestärkt. Ich bin sehr gespannt jetzt am Wochenende auf die Aufstellung. Léo und Theo hat dann nach dem Vorfall gebencht. Also die sind beim Spiel danach von der Bank gekommen, sind auch reingekommen, haben dann auch gut performt. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass Abraham und Tomori jetzt am Wochenende auch nicht anfangen. Bei Tomori muss man auch dazu sagen, das wäre leistungsmäßig auch mehr als verständlich. Also Tomori ist wirklich nicht mehr der Tomori, der noch vor zwei Jahren bei Milan war, als er wirklich dieser mitentscheidene Mann hinten im Abwehrzentrum war. Also Tomori muss sich wieder finden. Und ja, also es ist einfach sehr fragil alles und dementsprechend die Unkonstanz ist so ein bisschen die Konstanz momentan bei Milan. Und das ist schwierig, glaube ich, weil jetzt wirklich viele intensive Wochen kommen. Spiele im dreitagesrhythmus und da bräuchtest du wahrscheinlich mal so eine positive Serie, gerade von Seca, auch schon wieder. Obwohl man sich ja durch das Derby gegen Inter erst mal den Kopf aus der Schlinge gezogen hat.
Ja, spannende Situation bei Milan und Kudos Alex, du hast natürlich recht. San Lorenzos Trainer Leandro Romagnoli ist zurückgetreten, weil in der 94. Minute ein Spieler einen Strafstoß ausgeführt hat als Panenka. Und der Panenka war so schlecht, dass der Torhüter, der schon die falsche Ecke unterwegs war, noch Zeit hatte zurückzukommen und den Ball zu fangen. Und er hatte aber ausdrücklich gesagt, dass jemand anderes den Strafstoß schießen soll und ist dann zwei Tage nach dem Spiel hat er gesagt, also dann macht euren Kram alleine. Und er ist eine Legende bei San Lorenzo, hat mit denen die Coppa libertadores mal gewonnen. Also haben wir das hier auch noch mitbekommen.
Max, darf ich noch einen ganz kleinen Punkt, um das nur abzurunden, weil wir ja vielleicht auch hier beim Rasenfunk kleine Lösungsansätze präsentieren wollen. Ich finde, bei Milan spielt auch mit rein, dass über die letzten Jahre, das haben wir auch schon oft thematisiert, da hat sich viel getan. Viele Spieler wurden verkauft, neu gekauft, also viel Fluktuation. Und was bei Milan jetzt fehlt, gerade wenn man zum Beispiel auf Juve oder Inter schaut, also auf Juve die erfolgreiche Zeit noch vor Jahren und auf Inter jetzt die erfolgreichen letzten Jahren, es fehlt wirklich auch so ein harter Kern an italienischen Spielern, die wirklich den Verein dann auch tragen. Calabria ist der Kapitän, der spielt momentan kaum eine Rolle, war verletzt, da läuft der Vertrag aus, es ist die Frage, ob das vielleicht auch mit reinspielt. Und Calabria war lang der einzige Italiener in der Startformation. Jetzt hat sich Gabbia reingespielt. Gabbia hat wirklich auch gute Karten, der nächste Kapitän zu werden. Aber das zeigt einfach, wenn man an die alte Jubelmannschaft mit Buffon, Barzalli, Chiellini, Bonucci, früher noch Pirlo, Marquise, da war immer dieser harte italienische Kern, der auch diese DNA transportiert hat. Und Inter hat das in den letzten Jahren auch erfolgreich gemacht. Wenn wir uns Inter vor Jahren denken, dann war das noch internationale, also auch kaum Italiener. Und jetzt hast du diesen harten Kern mit Pastone, mit Di Marco, mit Acerbe, mit Darmian, mit fratesi, die wirklich auch diese Inter-DNA transportieren. Und das fehlt halt bei Milan komplett. Tonali ist ihnen auch deshalb so sehr abgegangen, nicht nur als Spielertyp, sondern auch, weil Tonali Milan wirklich im Herzen getragen hat und im Herzen auch gelebt hat. Und jetzt hast du Calabria, ein Kapitän, der selten spielt. Und jetzt kommt Gott sei Dank Gabbia. Ich glaube, der rückt da rein und der wird auch irgendwann der nächste Kapitän. Aber dann hast du eben diese Leaus und Theos, die zwar spielerisch wahnsinnig gute Einzelspieler sind, aber wo man schon manchmal die Frage stellen kann, ob die das große Ganze, Milan. Und Milan ist halt nun mal ein sehr, sehr großer Club, wirklich auch gerecht transportieren. Und deswegen glaube ich, ein Punkt auch für Milan sollte demnächst sein, dass du auch wieder so einen Stärkeren. Das müssen ja nicht nur italienische Spieler sein, wenn man an das Ante-Milan denkt. Und da waren ja auch die Seedorf und so. Seedorf war kein Italiener, aber Seedorf hat Milan gelebt. Und das braucht Milan wieder mehr, weil es auch bei den Fans teilweise immer wieder jetzt so kommt, dass die Identifikation eben nicht mehr so hoch ist, wie vielleicht noch vor ein, zwei, drei Jahren.
Da sind echt viele Baustellen offen. Die haben wir hier aber auch noch in dieser Sendung. Wir wollen jetzt nämlich noch ein paar Spieler aus podest heben. Spieler, die besonders wichtig waren in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Michi, du darfst da gerne mal loslegen für die Ligue 1. Über wen würdest du denn da gerne zuerst sprechen?
Ronda Colomboani hat ja sehr schwere Monate in Paris vergangenen Saison nicht möglichen Tritt gekommen, mit so EM gefahren, da ein bisschen besser unterwegs. Und diese Saison, obwohl Kian Mbappe weg ist, ist auch nicht die ganz große Rolle, die er spielt. Teilweise wird ihm dann ein Asensio vorgezogen, der kein absolut typischer Neuter ist, oder ein Kangin Lee, der aus Mallorca geholt wurde, damals eigentlich eher so als ein Marketingobjekt, der es aber gar nicht so schlecht macht. Ja, und jetzt hat er gegen Belgien getroffen, hat sich in der Nationalmannschaft viel Selbstvertrauen geholt, liegt aber auch daran, dass in der Nationalmannschaft ein bisschen anderer Fußball gespielt wird. Da wird er mehr mit Flanken geführt als in Paris. Und jetzt ist die Frage und die Hoffnung natürlich auch in Paris, dass er wieder zu Frankfurter Form aufläuft. Darauf hoffen sie jetzt schon seit über einem Jahr. Aber die Hoffnung ist da, dass man a. das System ein bisschen anpasst, man sollte ja meinen, dass Baccola und Dembélé, die auch sowohl im Club als auch in der Nationalmannschaft an seiner Seite stehen, dass sie ihm da ein bisschen Sicherheit geben. Allerdings ist das in Paris dann nicht so. Und jetzt, da er eben diesen Doppelpack erzielt hat gegen Berlin, besteht die Hoffnung in Paris umso mehr, als dass er da Fuß fasst. Und deswegen ist Ronald Alcolumbo nie mein Most Valuable Player.
yes. Und wenn du willst, dann schick doch gleich noch einen Spieler hinterher, der so ein bisschen unterm Radar läuft, aber positiv auffällt. Das ist nämlich auch jemand, den wir aus der bundesliga kennen.
Richtig, das ist Ludo Ajorg, der in Mainz gespielt hat, zuletzt kaum mehr eine Rolle gespielt hat. Aber jetzt in brest, die ja auch so ein bisschen unterm Radar gelaufen sind und in der vergangenen Saison dann aber die Champions-League-Qualifikation geschafft haben, der hatte eine ganz schwierige Aufgabe. Also brest war in der vergangenen Saison ein ganz klarer Überraschungsdritter. Da hat niemand damit gerechnet, dass die das so lang durchziehen. Die Mannschaft ist halt zusammengewachsen. Der Trainer, Uwe Rohr, ist ein Trainer, der sehr auf ein Belohnungssystem setzt, der auf Zusammenhalt setzt, der auf eine zusammengespielte Mannschaft gesetzt hat. Jetzt muss der sechs Stammspieler ersetzen. Und einer davon ist Dumbia, der ist nach Augsburg gegangen. Vorne drin spielt er und ihn hat er eben durch Ludo Ajoch ersetzt, der mit 30 Jahren jetzt in dem Alter ist, wo er anführen kann, wo er seine Erfahrung mit einbringen kann und das Hütter empresst. Er hat zwar begrenzte technische Fähigkeiten, auch wenn die gar nicht so schlecht ausgeprägt sind, aber es ist trotzdem begrenzend für die Liga. Aber er hat einfach eine Präsenz in dem Sturm, die man ihm so nicht zugetraut hatte nach der schwierigen Zeit in Mainz. Ich hatte die Woche mit Fronc Honorat von Gladbach gesprochen, der hat mit ihm zusammengespielt, kennt ihn schon länger, hat ihm zu dem Wechsel nach brest geraten. Honorat war ja selber drei Jahre in brest. Er hat ihn erhöht, hat es gemacht und fühlt sich jetzt sehr wohl. Sie haben in der Champions League zweimal gewonnen, sind da oben mit dabei, auch wenn es wahrscheinlich so bleiben wird. Erstmal spielen sie am Donnerstag gegen Leverkusen und mit einem Ludoweg Arjog in der Startelf, der den Leverkusen durchaus weh tun kann.
Das ist doch was von meins wegwechseln. Und dann erst mal zweimal Champions League spielen und in beiden Spielen jeweils einen Assist auflegen. Also Ludowig Arjog, definitiv ein Spieler, über den man reden sollte oder zumindest im Blick haben sollte. Und Alex hat auch zwei Spieler außer La Liga für uns. Einer davon vielleicht ein bisschen weniger überraschend als der andere.
Ja, bei meinem MVP wollte ich erst Robert Lewandowski wählen. Ich bin noch mal ungeschwungen, aber ich wollte ihn wählen, weil ich mal zehn Tore geschossen habe, Top Torjäger, Top Scorer mit zwölf Goals. Und es funktioniert unser Hansi Flick wieder richtig gut, macht halt Mittelstürmer-Dinge, steht wieder richtig, Barca spielt besser nach vorne. Also er ist eigentlich sehr obvious, deswegen fast schon ein bisschen langweilig. Aber ich wollte ihn erwähnen, dass man sieht, der trifft doch wieder im schlanken Alter von 36. Aber der für mich größere MVP ist tatsächlich Rafinha von Barca. Denn für mich der bisher beste Spieler in der Liga in der Saison. Und da ist ein bisschen eine bemerkenswerte Story dahinter. Denn aufgrund Marc-André testegns schwerer Verletzung wurde er zum ersten Kapitän. Also Barca hatte immer vier oder drei Kapitäne. Und da gibt es den ersten, zweiten, dritten, vierten. Rafinha wurde jetzt zum ersten, trägt seitdem die Binde und ist davon richtig, richtig beflügelt. Und hat das auch in einem Interview gesagt, dass ihm das noch mal eine zusätzliche Motivation gibt, dass das eine Ehre ist, dass er als Kind, obwohl er Brasilianer ist, ist ja nicht selten so, dass die Südamerikaner ein Fan von Barca, Real Madrid etc. sind. Er meint, er war als Kind schon Sympathisant oder Fan des FC Barcelona. Und dass er jetzt Kapitän dieses Vereins ist, ist für ihn was ganz, ganz besonderes. Also schon der Wechsel dahin von Leeds, da ging Traum in Erfüllung. Sportlich hat man das so nicht gesehen in den letzten Jahren zuvor, aber in dieser Saison wurde er wirklich noch mal besser unterflickt. Und du merkst, irgendwie mit dieser Kapitänsbinde hat er noch mal irgendwie einen zusätzlichen Impact und Push. Und die Leistungen sind wirklich herausragend. Fühlt sich auch wohl auf der linken Seite. Also normalerweise spielt er ja nur rechts unter Scharfi. Immer wenn er links eingesetzt wurde, hat er gar nicht gut funktioniert, weil er gerne nach innen zieht. Jetzt kommt er auch links zur Geltung. Richtig, richtig gute Saison. Ich glaube, fünf Assists, sechs Tore oder fünf Tore, fünf Assists, irgendwie sowas. Also richtig, richtig stark dabei. Und deswegen ist er mein MVP, dennoch jung in der Ligasaison bisher.
Stark. Und dann gibt es noch einen zweiten, bzw. jetzt sogar einen dritten Spiele, über den du sprechen wolltest. Wer ist es und warum?
Ja, das ist jetzt weniger eine sportliche geschichte. Und es ist ein Spanier-Spiel, aber nicht mehr in der Liga. Aber die Story muss man zumindest ganz kurz thematisieren. Denn Alvaro Morata, der Kapitän der spanischen Nationalmannschaft, hat ein ganz, ganz bemerkenswertes Interview gegeben. Und hat öffentlich über den Druck im Fußball und depression gesprochen in einer Klarheit, in einer Ehrlichkeit, die man sie so, finde ich, nicht kennt. Also zumindest aus Deutschland, wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht. Und das ist wirklich absolut bemerkenswert. Er ist ja zu Milan jetzt gewechselt, und das war ja ein bisschen kontrovers, denn er war ja der Stammstürmer bei Atletico und hat ja so schlecht nicht funktioniert. Nationalmannschaftskapitän, also die Leistungen müssen ja obviously gestimmt haben, ist trotzdem jetzt wieder nach Italien zum Christian. Ich glaube, zum dritten Mal ist er jetzt nach Italien, wenn mich ich täusche. Und das ist natürlich auch dann wieder eine Kontroverse gewesen, so ein bisschen, und er hat die Hintergründe erklärt. Und zwar meinte er ja, der öffentliche Druck in Spanien wurde für ihn zu groß, dass er depressionen hatte, dass er oder darunter leidet, dass er sogar in Behandlung ist und dass die Art und Weise, wie die Medien mit ihm umgehen, wie die Öffentlichkeit mit ihm umgeht, dass ihm das so zugesetzt hat, dass er flüchten musste. Er wollte Atletico eigentlich aus sportlichen Gründen nicht verlassen, musste es aber, weil er Spanien verlassen musste, weil es ihm so schlecht ging, weil er so darunter litt. Also ich haue jetzt mal ein paar Zitate raus. Wenn man– und das ist wirklich bemerkenswert– drei Monate vor der Europameisterschaft habe ich mich gefragt, ob ich überhaupt noch ein Spiel bestreiten kann. Ich wusste nicht, was genau mit mir geschah, aber es war sehr, sehr kompliziert. In dem Moment wurde einem klar, dass man das, was man am meisten liebt, dass das auch das ist, was man am meisten hasst. Und ich baue davon, dass er teilweise keine Luft bekam, dass er nicht die Kraft hatte, sich die Fußballschuhe zuzubinden, in manchen Momenten, weil er so depressive Schübe hatte oder Angstschübe. Ja, und dass die Situation für ihn bei Atletico in Spanien aufgrund dieses öffentlichen Drucks so groß war, dass er weg musste. Also man muss dazu wissen, er wird halt als Chancentod verschrien in Spanien und wird da immer stark kritisiert, wenn er mal wieder eine 100-prozentige Chance dafür gibt. Und er meinte auch, wenn er mit seinen Kids einkaufen geht, dass immer wieder Fans dann irgendwas sagen, was ihn halt, ja, was ihm richtig zusetzt. Und deswegen hatte er Angst, sogar teilweise am öffentlichen Leben teilzunehmen, weil ihn das so zugesetzt hat. Und deswegen musste er Spanien verlassen, um sich dieser Kritik zu entziehen. Und deswegen ist er nach Milan gewechselt. Wirklich absolut bemerkenswertes Interview. Also noch ein Zitat hinten ran. Wenn man wirklich harte Zeiten durchmacht, depressionen, Panikattacken, ist es egal, welchen Job man macht und in welcher Situation man sich befindet. Es gibt eine andere Person in dir, gegen die du jeden Tag und jede Nacht kämpfen musst. Für mich war es die beste Lösung, Spanien zu verlassen, denn ich konnte es hier nicht mehr er tragen. Also richtig, richtig bemerkenswertes Interview. Ganz, ganz wichtiges Thema, finde ich.
Und hat wahrscheinlich Christian in Italien auch Wellen geschlagen?
Ja, klar. Ich habe auch extra nochmal nachgeschaut, wie Alex ja auch gesagt hat. Er war ja zweimal davor schon bei Juwe. Und ich habe mir extra noch ein paar Interviews von ihm damals rausgesucht. Und da ist das auch schon durchgeklungen. Also das ist halt das, was ihn schon lange begleitet. Ich habe das Interview noch aus 2021 gefunden, in seinem zweiten Juwe-Aufenthalt. Und da hat er auch schon gemeint, der Druck, eben dieses in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, das beschäftigt ihn sehr. Also ich glaube, da reden wir jetzt nicht über was, was erst vor einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr bei ihm aufgetreten ist, sondern das hat ihn wirklich schon sehr lange begleitet. Und dementsprechend, glaube ich, ist es für ihn wirklich, so wie Alex ja gesagt hat, er hatte wirklich das Gefühl, er muss Spanien fluchtartig verlassen. Und es ist ihm wirklich zu wünschen, dass er in Italien jetzt wieder quasi eine gute Zeit findet. Denn seine Zeit in Turin, die war wirklich sehr positiv. Also er ist zwar ein Spanier, klar ist er kein Italiener, aber er hat sich auch oft gesagt, Turin ist für ihn auch eine zweite Heimat geworden. Seine Frau, von der er sich mittlerweile getrennt hat, ist ja auch Italienerin. Also er hat da wirklich einen sehr engen Bezug. Und deswegen war das jetzt zwar für ihn eine Flucht, aber ich glaube, er ist irgendwo hingekommen, wo er, glaube ich schon, ja, wo er schon in den Jahren davor halt sehr viele positiven Erfahrungen, sei ich jetzt auch mal Lebenserfahrungen gemacht hat. Klar, es ist in Mailand nicht Turin, aber es ist nicht weit entfernt. Dementsprechend ist ihm, glaube ich, wirklich zu wünschen, dass er wieder so ein bisschen persönliche Ruhe findet, eben auch mit den Kindern eben. Er hat ja vier Kinder. Das Thema hattet ihr letztes Mal ja auch schon. Da ist er ja auch sehr sensibel, was logischerweise die Öffentlichkeit betrifft rund um seine Kinder. Ja, also Morata ist schon sehr spezieller, sehr sensibler, aber das meine ich jetzt im Positiven. Ich bin Fußballprofi und da bin ich voll bei Alex. Ich glaube, es ist auch wichtig, dass Spieler dieser Größe, dieser Karatur dann so ein Thema auch mal öffentlich ansprechen, weil da doch vielleicht dann auch öffentliche Diskussionen in den Gang gehen.
Genau, man muss ein bisschen aufpassen, dann die Begriffe nicht durcheinander zu werfen. depression ist eine Krankheit und niemand bekommt wegen öffentlichen Drucks eine Krankheit. Da gibt es sehr interessante Aussagen auch von der teresa Encke, der Robert-Encke-Stiftung, dazu von teresa Encke, aber es spielt eben definitiv mit eine Rolle. Und wenn man eben selbst von etwas betroffen ist, muss man eben wissen, depressionen sind sehr gut behandelbar. Man muss Menschen, die davon betroffen sind, helfen, den Schritt zu schaffen, in diese Behandlung rein, weil dieser Schritt kann riesig, kann monumental aussehen und das sollte jeder von uns tun. Und dementsprechend ist es eben auch wichtig, dass wir hier an dieser Stelle so etwas thematisieren und da ist es eben auch sehr förderlich, wenn ein sehr prominenter Spieler da sehr offen drüber spricht. Das sind ja wirklich sehr eindrucksvolle Zitate von Alvaro Morata. Tja, irgendwie werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich trotzdem wieder aufs Sportliche zurückkommen. Es ist ja doch noch der Fokus dieser Sendung. Christian, wenn du eh gerade dein Mikrofon noch offen hast, über welche zwei Spieler würdest du denn gerne noch sprechen?
Ja, fangen wir mit dem MVP an. Das schließt so ein bisschen an Alex an. In Italien gibt es auch einen Herren, der munter drauf losknippst diese Saison. Das ist Matteo Retegi, Atalanta-Stürmer und Nationalstürmer. Hat jetzt siebenmal getroffen in den ersten sieben Ligaspielen, zuletzt vor der Länderspielpause in Hetrick, ein Dreierpack. Dazu noch eine Vorlage. Also ist wirklich in einer beneidenswerten Verfassung. Hat jetzt auch in der Länderspielpause in beiden Spielen für Italien getroffen. Und hätte auch noch mehr Buden machen können. Hat auch ein bisschen was liegen lassen. Aber Retegi hat wirklich den Sprung jetzt geschafft. Der ist ja im Sommer aus Genoa nach zu Atalanta gewechselt. Nachdem sich Skamaka, der eigentliche A-Stürmer von Atalanta und ja auch ein bisschen eigentliche A-Stürmer der Nationalmannschaft das Kreuzband gerissen hatte, hat Atalanta– schwupps-di-wupps– zwei Tage später Retegi geholt für 22 Millionen. Und das besondere daran ist, dass der wirklich null Anlaufzeit gebracht hat. Wie gesagt, sieben Tore, sieben Spiele. Also der ist dahin gekommen zu Gasperini, war sofort mit drin. Und wenn wir uns anschauen, was Gasperini in den letzten Jahren aus Offensivspielern rausgeholt hat, wenn wir schauen, was er aus Lukmen gemacht hat, wenn wir schauen, wie er es aus Skamaka gemacht hat, wenn wir schauen, was er aus Deketelare gemacht hat nach dem einen ersten so schwierigen Jahr bei Milan, dann zeigt das eben, dass Gasperini gerade auf die Offensivspieler einen großen Impact haben kann. Und wenn dann ein Spieler schon sofort funktioniert, dann können wir davon ausgehen, dass das in den nächsten Monaten auch nicht unbedingt schlechter wird, weil er wirklich einfach perfekt in dieses System reinpasst. Mittlerweile auch sehr gut in das Nationalmannschaftssystem. Das sind nicht nur Tore, er funktioniert auch gut als Wandspieler, war immer schon einer, der sehr fleißig war, ist ja gebürtiger Argentinier, bringt auch wirklich diesen argentinischen Piss gegen den Ball mit. Und darauf konntest du dich eh schon immer verlassen. Wenn du jetzt auch noch so verlässlich knippst, dann ist das sehr beeindruckend. Und letzter Satz dazu, mich erinnert es sehr an Luqman, denn Luqman kam auch zu Atalanta und hat sofort funktioniert. Das war wirklich, er hat keine Einlaufzeit bei Gasperini gebraucht. Das war vor zwei Jahren, wenn wir gesehen haben, wohin der Weg von Luqman geführt hat, was er letzte Saison auch in der Europa League angestellt, was er jetzt auch weiter in der Champions League macht. Dann ist da, glaube ich, wirklich bei Retegi noch weiterhin Potenzial da.
Und dann hast du noch jemanden, der so ein bisschen unterm Radar läuft, aber auch…
Genau. Ja, er läuft unterm Radar im Kontext. Ich wollte kurz auf Napoli schauen. Napoli ist der Tabellenführer und der Konter. Lukaku im letzten Spiel vor der Pause, zwei Tore gemacht, eins vorbereitet. Quaratzkelia funktioniert, neres funktioniert von der Bank. McDominick hat jetzt sein erstes Tor erzielt. Also, es gibt genügend geschichten bei Napoli, wo wieder viele Offensiven im Fokus stehen, so wie im Meisterjahr Osemen und Quaratzkelia. Aber der eine Mann, der wieder dahin gekommen ist, wo er auch im Meisterjahr war, ist Lobotka. Und deswegen funktioniert Napoli auch so langsam wieder, wie das Napoli, was viele von uns noch vor eineinhalb Jahren gekannt haben. Am letzten Spieltag, jetzt, war echt eine wunderschöne geschichte vor der Länderspielpause. Napoli gewinnt 3-1 gegen Como. Der Trainer von Como, wie ihr wisst, Fabregas, also einer, dem ich zugestehen würde, der ein bisschen gespür hat für diese Position, meinte nach dem Spiel, Zitat, Mama mia, Lobotka, was für ein Spieler. Gebt ihm mir bitte, wie der das Spiel liest, wie er das Spiel versteht, wie er die Bälle gewinnt. Um die ganze Mannschaft dreht sich um ihn. Das war direkt nach dem Spiel bei der Zone, unten am Spielfeldrand. Auf der pressekonferenz hat er noch mal zwei Minuten über Lobotka geredet, hat gemeint, ich will elf Lobotkas in meiner Mannschaft. Also ich will eine Mannschaft, die aus elf Lobotkas besteht. Daraus würde ich meinen Fußball kreieren. Xavi hat letzte Saison, als Napoli gegen Barca gespielt hat, öffentlich über ihn gesprochen. Ist auch in Italien verbrieft, dass Barcelona im Sommer wieder angeklopft hat bei Lobotka. Da hat sich Conte aber vehement gewehrt. Also was ich damit sagen will, er ist der klassische Spieler, über den vielleicht öffentlich nicht immer so viel geredet wird, aber der gerade für diese Art und Weise, wie Napoli Fußball spielt, unfassbar wichtig ist. Und Conte weiß das auch. Und es gab eine Szene, er hat ihn jetzt gegen Como, er hat ihn in der 89. ausgewechselt, wissend, dass es Standing-O-Mations geben würde. Und als er rauskam, hat er ihn umarmt und geküsst. Also quasi wirklich vor aller Augen. Und wer Conte kennt, weiß, das ist nicht einer, der Spieler gerne, sag ich mal, in der Öffentlichkeit so quasi herausbickt und über die anderen stellt. Aber da hat er eben gemerkt, hat sie ihn auch übermahnt, hat er danach selber erzählt, er wollte einfach Lobotka diese Bühne geben. Und ich habe mich auch deshalb für Lobotka entschieden, weil er sich jetzt in der Nationalmannschaft verletzt hat. Fällt jetzt wohl die nächsten zwei Wochen aus, verpasst mindestens zwei Spiele, vielleicht auch das Milan-Spiel, den ersten großen Kacher jetzt, Ende des Monats. Und deswegen wird es spannend sein, wie Napoli seinen Ausfall jetzt erstmal verkraftet. Vielleicht sieht man nochmal mehr, wie viel er wert ist. Aber Gilmour wird jetzt reinrutschen, der bekommt seine Chance und deswegen Lobotka als ein Spieler, der vielleicht nicht immer im Fokus steht.
Steht hiermit offiziell auf einer Stufe mit Dante, denn auch da hat ein Trainer mal gesagt, ich hätte gerne Elf dantes. 1000 dantes, oder?
50.000?
Ja, vielleicht waren sogar mehr. Das wäre ein Fußballspiel, das würde ich auch gerne sehen. Elf dantes gegen Elf Lobotkas. Dann schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Dann lasst uns nochmal auf die Premier League blicken, Uli, zwei Spieler, die du gerne hier aufs podest heben würdest.
Also mein MVP ist wirklich ein echter solcher. Ich nehme Bria im Bümo von Brentford. Die sind ordentlich gestartet mit dem vergleichsweise leichten Programm. Zwar aber zehn Punkte aus sieben Spielen. Das ist sehr gut. Im Bümo hat er gleiche Zahlen wie Retegi. Sechs Tore in sieben Spielen. Das ist deshalb so wichtig, weil er so extrem gefehlt hat und die fast noch Richtung Abstieg geguckt hätten. Vergangenen Saison, als er nicht mit dabei war. Vor allen Dingen, weil Ivan Toni kurz vor Ende der Transferperiode nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt ist. Der immer so als derjenige galt, ohne dem nichts geht. Wir haben bei Click & Rush auch schon gesagt, dass das eher ein Bümo ist und nicht so sehr Toni. Der macht jetzt genau da weiter, wo er eigentlich aufgehört hat, bevor er sich letzte Saison schwer verletzt hat. Er ist ein super Abschlussspieler, sehr zielgerichtet, ist ständig in die Tiefe unterwegs, arbeitet nach hinten. Er ist eigentlich so was wie der offensive Fixpunkt und so schwierig zu verteidigen, weil er auch so kompakt ist als Spieler und sehr schnell, sehr direkt, aber auch ein gutes Trickrepertoire hat, sodass der, glaube ich, wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des wortes wertvolles der Spieler genannt werden muss für Brentford.
Aber ist das jetzt eine jüngere Entwicklung, weil er spielt da jetzt schon viele Jahre bei Brentford, kam von Thora?
Die Wichtigkeit ja, die Effizienz, würde ich auch sagen, ist deutlich besser geworden. Aber alles in allem war der schon, also der Kern bei Brentford ist sowieso seit Jahren der gleiche. Das kann man auch als Kritikpunkt sehen, aber das ist im Grunde genommen der selbe Kern, der aufgestiegen ist und die Premier League seither bestreitet. Der war nicht immer ganz gesund. Ich würde auch immer noch ein Fragezeichen dahinter setzen, ob das über 38 Spiele so gehen kann in dieser Saison. Aber der entwickelt sich einfach steht. Der hatte, wie klassisch Brentford-Spieler das haben, Löcher, als sie ihn geholt haben im Spiel. Hatte aber brutale Stärken. Damals waren wir kurz vor Corona noch im alten Brentford-Stadion. Da haben wir nur beim Aufwärmen zugeguckt und haben gesagt, das ist ja Wahnsinn, was der für einen Abschluss hat. Da ist jeder einzelne Ball scharf drin. Das kommt jetzt langsam aber sicher auch in der Premier League an. deswegen würde ich sagen, das sind relativ stete Entwicklungen. Es ist aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich immer noch kein Spieler, der jetzt allerorts auf den Schirmen wäre.
Wenn man sich die letzten Premier League-Saisons anguckt, hat er ja auch vier Tore, neun Tore, neun Tore. Jetzt hat er schon sechs, nach sieben Spielen. Also auf einem hervorragenden Weg, das mal zu übertreffen und dann im Brandenlicht zu stehen. Und dann gibt es ja auch immer die Spieler, die so ein bisschen untergehen, die Lobotkas, wie ich so gerne sage, dieser Welt. Wen gibt es denn da in der Premier League, Uli?
Ich habe jetzt einfach mal stellvertretend Carlos Baleba rausgesucht von Brighton, den wahrscheinlich jetzt noch nicht die Allermeisten kennen werden, der 18 Monate in Lille gespielt hat, davor aus Cameroon kam, da war er noch viel unbekannter, dann nach Brighton gegangen ist. Und dann hat im Januar der Zerbi über ihn gesagt, ah, da fehlt es aber noch weit, bis der Premier League-Spieler sein kann. Zwei Wochen später ist er Stammspieler. Und nochmal fast-forward, jetzt Runde neun Monate später sieht er aus wie einer, der im zentralen Defensiven Mittelfeld alles können könnte, ist physisch, kann 6er, könnte 8er, ist ein unglaublicher Ball-Carrier, also es kann sehr, sehr vertikal das Spiel ankurbeln, ist clever im Antizipieren, super geschickter Spieler einfach und hat eine Laufleistung, die habe ich so noch nicht gesehen, ist auch glaube ich ganz wichtig bei diesem Bielsa-artigen Hürzeler-Fußball in Brighton im Moment und glaube einer, von dem wir sehr, sehr viel hören werden. Also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das der nächste ist, den dann alle irgendwann mal wollen.
Carlos Baleba, hier habt ihr den Namen zuerst gehört. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ja ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht mit euch mal wieder heute über ein breites Thebenspektrum über europäischen Fußball bei den Männern zu sprechen. Ich danke sehr herzlich. Michi Postel, danke, dass sie hier warst.
Danke auch.
Herzlichen Dank an Alex Treuker, auch noch gemutet.
Sehr gerne, es ist mir immer wieder eine Freude.
Schön, dass du hier warst. Danke, Christian. Vielen Dank auch. Danke dir.
Viel Spaß gemacht.
Und herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Schön, dass du trotz engem Terminplan immer noch schaffst, hier wieder rein zu sneaken in die Ligatur. Danke dir.
Ach ja, ich komme halt immer so zehn Minuten später, aber dann ist alles erledigt. Danke auch.
Ich lasse jetzt alle Gags, die hier liegen und vielleicht mit Kollegen von uns allen zu tun haben, liegen und sage danke euch und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für euren Support, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert, damit auch die Gästehonorare, die wir zahlen. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei einfachfrida, bei faröing, bei domsen, bei ante martin und bei torben l. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Sie sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangenundhaben uns unterstützt. Ihr könnt auch auf rasenfunk.de gehen und einfach auf unterstützen klicken. Viele Wege führen zum Rasenfunk-Support, also keine Ausreden. Auch kleine Beträge helfen. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die es getan haben. Und danke, wenn ihr diese Folge weiter empfiehlt, wenn ihr uns Feedback dalasst und wenn ihr auch die anderen Rasenfunk-Feeds abonniert. Es gibt 5 einfach nach Rasenfunk in der Podcast-App. eures Vertrauen zu. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald, macht's gut. Ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!